oh [ __ ] it's Monday for [ __ ] 20
greeting some podcast Ville you bad
[ __ ] kick this [ __ ]
mealy
[Music]
I love you [ __ ] happy 4/20 to
you don't worry about what's going on
you know that's going on as you you're
alive you're kicking you're trying to
put two pieces together but so is
everybody else but right now it's four
[ __ ] twenty I got my main brother in
the house with the mask and everything
Jorge Perez I got stymie over here he
don't wanna do nothing it's hilarious
I feel sitting across in Georgia I feel
like whoa
with two drug dealers on drugs Inc yeah
hey watch drugs yeah every Friday man I
go out there but I sell [ __ ] met a
little white kids and you see the guy
yeah now I'm gonna go to gorillas house
you know he's even watch that shop no
just a show called drugs Inc on travel
something like that drugs Inc and the
sell drugs that have an uber they
[ __ ] show every city they break down
every city they got a drug dealer they
show you the the components of the city
what makes up the drugs what part of the
city they sell them I'll give you the
life and day of two or three drug
dealers that's everybody's got a word
mask this year and you see him picking
up the coke yeah and they all got street
names now weighing Killa and they'll
type up to and they've been having the
coronavirus for years they always got
bandanas on these glasses you remember
the 70s had glasses to make you look
Chinese
yeah what yeah they had lasses that like
a glaze on them and it was apply that so
I made people think you were Chinese
I don't know Lee it was like a 3d
glasses I don't ask questions
I just bought him doing my job
it was like giving away 50 cents here do
you take this I don't know it's for 20
[ __ ] we was good at my wall so want
to give a shout out the weed maps
dot-com I did a video for them this
morning it's up and rocket on my
Instagram and it's also on Twitter I
don't know where the [ __ ] I know it's
on Instagram and I'm part of the
festival this afternoon for weed maps
calm so I'll forget about that what's
been going on George Perez you know
just live in this quarantine life you
know trying to try not to be a weenie
during the quarantine II oh you know I
just like I you know we talked Joey I
love you you call me like every other
day or check in on me and like it's just
been a bonding time but the kids my kids
are older younger and just living it up
role you know what else can you do at
this point I already wrote out my
obituary when you're walking around this
scan I want you to do with general
whatever told this men right out your
[ __ ] ooh Aryan your [ __ ] usual
eulogy yeah you what you want the right
guy to write that's it all you do that
you could be a new [ __ ] man the next
day trust me when I'm done yet
I'm for joining online uh none of his
nephews you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart
are you scared are you having anxiety do
me a favor right you [ __ ] [ __ ] aware
II the whole thing Joey Diaz aka buttons
aka yes
born in Havana I grew up in North Bergen
deceased daughter and leaves behind a
wife and a Jewish [ __ ] mutas you know
the whole thing I wrote right out your
obituaries write out your eulogy what
you want people to say about you I wrote
a letter I'm a fat [ __ ] he was a good
dude he respected comedy you know he's a
thief and like but when it came to
comedy did it right you know I wrote a
[ __ ] eulogy out and that's it move on
guys if Corona gets you and gets you a
dozen or you could do is wash your hands
wear a mask and don't bother stay away
from people beside that you're doing the
right thing so you need money so does
everybody else
yeah wait it out go to the advance
paycheck that ring you got on you can't
eat it
yeah you can't eat it I've been telling
you for years that car you bought
against everybody's wishes you can't eat
it go sell it [ __ ] light on fire in
Mexico I don't get what you gotta sell
to the cartel this is what you need to
do now George I give you props you even
[ __ ] got a job yeah I got a job dude
I clean officer
this is it this is like this will people
understand this is why you're on the
show they don't let people know that
what comedians but yeah we do whatever
the [ __ ] it takes yeah I mean humbling
when you told me I was like wow at least
one guy got it that you know you have a
dream that dream right now gets put on
hold right now you gotta feed your
family straight up a printer clean
offices you know that bring rinse wood a
clean offices and with the money he'd
use it a studio time parents dog this
isn't this is do or die
you know I know people are hurting
I don't know that everybody's waiting
for that check but some people are never
gonna come some years got it you know I
filled out the form four times and it's
rejected me four times yeah you know
unemployment people await and some
people have had success I'm not here to
be a doom I told you a long time ago to
get you itself a little side gig
sometimes if you're busy just keep your
mind off yes to is a Mexican but um I'm
like third generation okay my dad was
born here my grandpa and I was okay and
I work with og immigrant Mets kids right
now and I forgot how dope my people are
from my native land dawg when you when
you work with an immigrant is I showed
up to work one day with no lunch and
this fool was like doesn't your lady
love you owe me then you came with no
lunch you know me I had a six-pack and
I'm taking this as a party dog I got
sidekick Eddie working with me where
ever we take two beers in our pocket
every time we go clean a restroom boom
pound it wash our hands wash our face
boom go right back out and this Bice I
had his wife make me lunch dog how dope
is that yeah you know I broke it down
psychologic I was like damn this full
woke his lady up in the morning was like
not you got to make one more for George
cuz nice yeah and uh
I kind of like how like um I'm informed
about the Cova dog
like I talked to inspectors and they
tell me like hey you know what you're
spraying on there do you know why we're
doing this [ __ ] and whether it be
man-made or hoaxes or anything the state
of California is not [ __ ] around
yesterday I cleaned an old we cleaned a
courthouse that's going to get
demolished but they're scared that the
corona lived in there and then when they
demolition the building it's gonna
spread and hit people
these same idealist chemicals and bring
them home and yeah [ __ ] you spray
everything I spray the cats I spray
killer tell him Joey
[ __ ] around you know Sam yeah we square
everything everything gets clean my
[ __ ] office is spotless I can tell I
wipe down the [ __ ] the computer now
this is the new modern you know this is
a new thing but no I admire you that
thank you but strip club closed down the
Brea Broncos they raided my strip book
and they yeah we were there you find did
you find no so what happened is is they
came by and they gave everybody a letter
hey check it out if you are not in
between these guidelines of social
distancing like 10 customers max six
feet apart and my boss don't [ __ ] around
she gave all the strippers masks all the
strippers had had this they had like a
little ziploc bag that they put their
money in so I wouldn't touch the purse
or get anything infected and you're
getting hand sent it before you got a
lap dance both of you guys would get
Hanson ties and they just came in the
sheriff's they didn't draw their guns
but they came in with the warrant in
their leg like old school dog everybody
get the [ __ ] out everybody just left and
then they sat us down they said hey man
if we come back it's a thousand dollar
fine but but there was a club that
stayed open did you see that it came out
on the news what bliss yeah it stayed
open Joey they were doing fever checks
on
people outside that's some [ __ ] but I'll
tell you the sad part man is these girls
are crying on the way out like honestly
what does a stripper gonna do right now
joy
deliver weed yeah yeah because any
deliveries are up weed right now all
dispensaries are legally open like if
you go on we've managed calm and look
that they're really medicinal marijuana
isn't her their delivery services have
gone up dramatically this nobody goes
out let's take up in trees where I go
okay their sales right now in ninety
five five five five percent of their
sales is walk-up you could to save this
place right now in LA is urban cherry
trees okay you got walk in there I go in
there with a mass to give you gloves
they're outside the door is open no way
that's why I go the urban trees cuz the
door is open
I'm not going anywhere with this fresh
air yeah I have always been a [ __ ]
nag about that I don't I get close to
phobic mm-hmm I get what I seen you in a
car you wrote the one down every time
every time let's get let's get some air
down let's get some air in this car were
you're breathing I'm breathing what the
[ __ ] are we doing yeah this is 2020 is
the mass killing you 20,000 people huh
the mass is killing me dawg when you
when I work out my backyard only use a
mass but you got a walk
you really gotta walk a couple of days a
week you gotta walk a little bit every
day and I was walking and I was doing
fine oh my god I had to walk with a mask
whoo
different [ __ ] ball park had dog I
had to stop a couple times and make
believe I was stretching but I was
really trying to get my life together
like I was about to die
you try to walk like up a hills I walked
and I walked down the Riverside I walked
through it you know and I try to walk
off the beaten path I don't want to walk
where I'm walking behind people yeah so
to do that you have to do it early
because people start to go out around
here about three once they've done all
their work and their kid
done with homeschooling so three o'clock
in this area the streets are packed so
you're breathing what everybody else is
breathing yeah thanks to your potential
so what I do is I do something with her
early and bring her back and then I have
time to do it
so I usually take the car park and go
somewhere and walk okay to an unpopular
I'm not gonna go to a park know what I
love to go to that Park I know ho I
would love to go to a bunch of parks but
every one of them I've driven to every
one of them Beeman as a path they're all
out there and I can't blame them that's
the obvious choice when you're drunk you
drive on fountain Yeah right drunk you
drive on found rocks unser so this is
right so this is the same thing here
people are going to parks so you don't
want to walk around that and then small
neighborhoods people start coming on
around 3:00 3:30 and walking and then
you bump into people it's okay I found
parking lots where I take my daughter
and she just spins around I'm just
trying to burn her out bro yeah so when
I first take her out in the morning
that's with a scooter then I switch it
up to the bicycle and then about 3:30 I
pull her out again just kind of sitting
there listening to the news that's got
the last little bit of the Sun and then
in between that I tried to take a walk I
was doing fine until I tried walking
with a mask and that was [ __ ] crazy
bro
so last three walks I've taken I've been
with a mask when they've been rough
rough where I had a pee and [ __ ] like I
was getting anxiety rough I couldn't
breathe yeah it's a new obstacle so I'm
gonna try it every other day just to
walk a little bit yeah I feel weird
wearing the mask and the gloves his dog
Tommy this doesn't remind you I am I
don't know about you but I I did some
bad things in life and I used to [ __ ]
rob people or break into our house and
this is this is the feel leave that's
the field leave this is it like right
now I could do something and get away
with it like a dog there's no
fingerprints
the [ __ ] on you can't see me really like
does it actually like make you feel like
that you get adrenaline or something
yeah I get anxiety I even tell people
hey dog get away you might get took
Rhino gloves on was that so creepy I
tried to rob I tried to rob a bookmaking
one night I would wear those gloves
under a pair of whole Jake gloves
oh [ __ ] Oh Jake killed Nicole Josh I had
a pair of those not the French the fancy
ones yeah but that style I know what you
mean it was 1983 it's like a it's like a
chauffeur kinda that was fitted it was
February it was still cold in Jersey all
I wanted to rob this bookmaker so I put
a pair of those gloves underneath
I had a screwdriver had a weapon and I
had a pair of oj gloves and I had a run
in them getting caught I didn't get
caught I got the cops came before I can
break the seal on the window huh until
this day I have a scar on my right and
once they told me I was going to lose
the movement of my finger mm-hmm the
reason why this was so tough bus because
the Bob why I got caught and it ripped
the glove and the other glove got caught
together yeah and I didn't all with with
cocaine and booze I'm a doc and David
I'm just cocaine and booze I took this
glove off I was walking around like
Michael Jackson for a day I just walk
around with a glove on and the glove was
drenched from the blood so whenever I'm
gonna put the glove down I would take my
glove up and there would be a mist of
blood where I slept there was a
fingerprint of blood like it was like a
guy slept there and they cut his hand
off I think he hated blood why are you
wearing a dinner girl because I [ __ ]
couldn't even imagine going to the
doctor the glove was black so it didn't
tell the picture of blood so it didn't
let me faint yeah the whole night in the
ball I went there and I was
oh but I was drinking this is just to
show you this in New Jersey yes this is
just what some people go look at those
[ __ ] in the flyer than are out with
man this is our time we gotta put that
would have been me
I wanted missed I was talking to a
friend of mine in there then he goes oh
he thinks that it's easier for the kids
today to stay home because they've been
staying home because of the computer age
and yams and technology he goes that
this would have happened when we were
growing up it would have never worked
now it would have never worked as we
were so addicted to being out he
would've never would it would have never
worked right now as it was in my
hometown I heard they closed the park
and people kept jumping the fence and
playing basketball so they took the rims
down people kept jumping the fence and
playing basketball against the backboard
and then they had to come in and take
the backboards down Wow like but this is
what people do they want to get out and
jump
so you're caught in this [ __ ] in the
realm of do you stay in how much do you
push the envelope you know and that's
what I'm just trying to do because I'm
right there so I'm just trying to keep
it light for right now yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] one day open I have my own agenda
I'm not going on the road so I got my
dates and I already know I'm gonna duel
you know I think they're gonna cancel
Cleveland and what Wensley annapolis
June 21st ah yeah Miami just got cancer
with Kim condom okay
Miami's it's a nice done baby 15 Miami
was done we were supposed to be in
Addison and right that got passed up
January
oh [ __ ] somebody asked me on refunds
yesterday I'm told that I think
Ticketmaster said no more refunds so
they pushed the El Paso date to January
who knows what's gonna be happening in
January who knows if Texas gonna have a
quarantine so that means we gotta go
there two weeks before the [ __ ] show
you know who knows
the restrictions are gonna be all you
could do right now all I know I got on
the books is July 31st in Las Vegas and
I'll expect it
I got August 1st in San Diego I don't
expect it how low it's gonna happen Jake
June and Brea yeah
June 4th through the 6th it might be
open but we could only do 80 people for
sure but is that gonna be the rule
they're not gonna open it up - God said
he already said no thousands or more
gathered yesterday in Huntington Beach
yeah there was 500 people out no mass
flags and [ __ ] [ __ ] you those they
showed the one guy Colvin is alive but
he still had a million mass if the mass
doesn't fit you must have but the mass
don't fit yeah listen I see these
numbers spiking I see high area place is
not coming back for a while now [ __ ]
I got a blended Jews the Jews yeah do
you want me to tell you why New York and
Worcester be getting it so hard it's not
because like Florida is getting it
because of knuckleheads it's just a lot
of old people it's going through nursing
homes but you want me like I know two
people for a fact for my own town three
of them got it
the mother died the wife survived oh
they were all on a ball on st. Paddy's
Day st. Paddy's weekend was the killer
they closed the number they didn't
happen in LA and I don't think they had
though at all New York and Boston but
people still got to go yeah I'm sure of
course thank you
and the Irish everybody ways into that
[ __ ] yeah my response I love a
holiday it's it's not listen if you're
Irish you know the glass of whiskey at
home is the same as having a good you
know saying you live with your family
yeah that family orientated clan anyway
you're with your family at the house I
think it was the aliens that weekend
that was the weekend Michael yo got it
that was the weekend of the big
explosion okay that was the weekend Alex
let's go to New York there's hot baddies
that it would have been [ __ ] up right
now if God would have known what would
happen so well speaking to what George
said earlier my mom used to live in a
city a town named Chelsea which is like
right outside of Boston
and she was saying like that and I read
the articles of that that cities the
biggest city in Boston it has like rates
like New York because it's a lower
middle class neighborhood and more
people that have to go to work I'm sure
I'm sure the the rates of this our work
areas again yeah we're gonna put some
masks on all right you know what though
I'm kind of scared that on Cinco DeMayo
my people ain't they ain't gonna stay
home I mean if we do I mean they're not
gonna open up bars okay there's not
gonna be bars open but I guarantee you
they're gonna be at the [ __ ] Park in
the morning they're gonna be at the
backyards all that whatever if if your
dad owns property that no one's there it
is gonna be a party they mean Passover
what are the Jews do did you guys they
did it around online party Seder Staters
and Cinco de Maya look insane
I give him a lot of respect that's
what's up yummy taste and I watched a
few of them it was kind of nice you know
but George I feel you and at this point
listen we've been educated or lighter
either way you got a choice them back
you could be safe or you could be sorry
the rest is up to you I can't control
what your actions are no I feel the
government can't control what your
actions are either but I also want other
consequences I also want you to know
that from here on in they're gonna
[ __ ] when you get that bill in the
mail for the eight eight month stay if
you think that stimulus check is gonna
pay for that you're [ __ ] wrong those
nurses again more than $28 a day so
they're getting nurses a magnet making
good money in New York that's what's
going on in Syracuse and Albany and
places like that
the nurses are leaving those in
hospitals and go on to New York because
they're paying about 28 yeah a [ __ ]
hour [ __ ] face mask and whatever that's
a lie [ __ ] well that's a [ __ ] that
could bring you back after a month so
yeah oh there's a lot of things people
don't know you know that that's [ __ ]
crazy
I mean what's Cuba doing dick Cuba get
hit harder I don't think so because yeah
cuz socialist countries no one goes in
or out right yeah so I think an Italian
brought it in on vacation and they
contained it but I haven't heard much
about it I spoke to my uncle the other
day he had he said he hasn't spoken to
my aunt a few days I had to call my aunt
because Greg Fitzsimmons is going to
Cuban I wasn't hook him up in Cuba and
my aunt was gonna try just for like
welcome um yeah at the airport
let him know what stuff a good
restaurant not to go to yeah I was gonna
get him what a night at my factory yeah
I don't let him go up you know I don't
know what the agenda is of a factory so
that's the last time I don't know I
don't really know the statistics in Cuba
I was Mexico Mexico's bad bro
real bad Mexican I heard that I spoke to
a dear friend of mine Kimo who was at
the show in Vegas I spoke I checked them
days later because they were on that way
Guns and Roses have canceled all their
shows except for Mexico City hell [ __ ]
like that was the weirdest and like
people like really you cancel the whole
tour except Mexico City but like I guess
Guns and Roses flew down down on stage
and we're in planes within 30 minutes of
the performance Wow back to Hawaii and I
gotta guess a week later
Mexico City got round you know killed by
the [ __ ] shitstorm yeah I don't know
it was it's so bad in Mexico that the
president shut down alcohol sales cuz
people were always going to bars going
out to get a beer he shut down alcohol
sales so everybody just loaded the [ __ ]
up to get alcohol and come on dawg
there's no money out there for like
hospitals and anybody doing bad it's you
know who's helping out Mexico right now
man the cartels the cartels that run
that area they're out there and even on
the package you know that you know how
like the Red Cross will give you a box
Mexico and I seen him I didn't see it in
person but I seen it on the Internet
where the Sinaloa cartel that won't from
Marcos the badass [ __ ] they're
all bad I'm not saying but like they
were giving boxes to everybody just say
hey you know what the government says
they protect you and help you all that
not we take care of you guys because
it's a territorial thing with them you
know what I mean take care of us and you
see anybody that doesn't belong you're
out of place this holler at me that's
really interesting that's really
interesting in the narcos are doing away
they got the money straight up did that
mob do something there's a Thanksgiving
everybody did something but it would
help me know I had the [ __ ] turkey a
4th of July
it's funny if you read the book people
would say that
Sammy the bull book he goes yeah they'd
be hundreds of people that are eating
[ __ ] hot dogs they'd be puking him up
knowing how he made that money that
there was heroin money yeah you know
they weaned those hot dogs and burgers
[ __ ] huh the black dude the one that
taught what's-his-name bumpy Johnson be
Johnson he was he gave up Turk yeah they
know Brown
exactly no Jack city and all that but
what we talkin about like that how the
yeah this is this is a what do you guys
think about like this cultures like your
Spanish culture and black culture like
there's a lot of cultures that like live
on hugs and like a lot of oh yeah do you
think that's not like we adjusted dogs
at the end of the day we try now but do
you think you're gonna like is it gonna
be like when this is over - this is like
going to church just because you go to
church just because you don't put a
video up of you bringing pizzas to a
[ __ ] Hospital just because you don't
do these things doesn't mean I'd help
your community it's like I'm a big mask
guy so far I wasn't what two boxes a
[ __ ] mask and then what knocked on my
doors and my neighbors will need to
[ __ ] mass ask us up you know I saw a
chick running the a day with no math I
pulled up next door I just put a mask
out the window you know yeah I mean it's
a saw saying ah it's the same thing with
as long as you're doing something nice
on everyone a daily basis my wife
dropped off will close his [ __ ] I saw
this this people they opened up ah a
homeless thing for men right here in the
dirty side of North Hollywood so they
needed sweatpants so I had a bunch of
sweatpants when when I weighed 400
pounds
[ __ ] it's a bunch of skinny guys walk
around
you gotta do what you need to do and the
cartel they're animals they're savages
but they also come from a Spanish
culture yeah the hogs do whatever it's
the same thing I don't have to give you
a big you ever go out at night you were
gonna like a black claw meat well mm-hmm
you know these two brothers hate each
other they see each other in public
that's a big and a big hug and
everybody's happy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what's the hug for yeah what's what the
[ __ ] straight-out [ __ ]
so this is gonna cut out a lot of
[ __ ] you don't need to hug me you
know we need a hug but unless you got a
wife or a girlfriend you ain't gonna get
unless moms around and you a mama [ __ ]
you know you wanna do something nice go
to one of those old folks home knock on
the glass you show me a dick and run
away ran over the couch at least I'll
have a little entertainment of my life
I'm saying just did you [ __ ] just
because there's a quarantine doesn't
mean you still can't have fun oh hell I
have Matt I was taller but I time to
starting to practice I was telling you
before the podcast about me [ __ ] the
walls closing down on me about a week
ago and I [ __ ] called Lee and I go
what are you doing there I go before you
do a twitch hold on I put my pants on I
ran to the weed store and I bought three
containers of that juju juice the
[ __ ] the quickies quick Zee I bought
three of them cuz I ran over the Lee's
house and I drank one and Lee drank one
leave is making faces [ __ ] you what's on
the way home that [ __ ] wants to hit me
yeah that [ __ ] must've hit me because
it's a body body high right hit you
right away liquid I think I think it's
the liquid so it hits you rather wait
100 milligrams it's not a lot of
milligrams but with that stood the
quickies I take this to sleep it does
put Brown woke up a [ __ ] tent and I'm
just
those things last night I slept like a
baby so I drank one by gamely one I
watched Li drink is and it must have hit
me and I was driving down I just tell
the story and I'm driving down the
street it's gotta be ten to ten I'm
minding my own business but let me go
back well that was a kid my buddy had a
funeral parlor and he was a great kid we
loved him to death but in the every
morning at eight o'clock he would put
cones out just cones out in front of his
property me and my friends would be
snoring the coach and every day we knew
an eight between eight and eight ten
that's what a flower car comes and they
start loading the flowers up and then
they put the body in the I got you now
own cost saving the spot so what they do
is they would have to lows morning at
nine o'clock
uh-huh and one 11 o'clock we had it
timed so it's 1984 we would drink behind
a coal factory the cops was the populace
it was a coal factory and we would snort
coke behind there we will put mirrors on
top all it's a cause we'd be back there
from 4:00 in the morning and then 8:00
you run out of beer and I had a friend
who would go we gotta go take care of
some and right before they with the
whole family would be standing in front
of a funeral parlor my friend who was
like you would be with his black suit
cause you're on the funeral parlor and
then my other buddy would run over the
cones in front of them and my friend
would just close his eyes see my friends
go what the [ __ ] is wrong with you but
we went from that just if we see a cone
you gotta hit it just on principle yeah
you got a cone I'm either gonna hit it
I'm gonna steal it but I'd love like
what this instruction I'm gonna sideways
Ashley I've been I've been with him
coming back from the brain improv and I
hit three or four clones just a
principal I've always loved income one
one night one got stuck and everything I
love it so there's a house and this is
this guy holds it I guess I don't know
who the guy is but he's got cold in his
driveway and it's like him and the guy
next to him think back to you and they
have cones in their driveway to let
people know like you can't make a u-turn
yeah I don't want your traffic on it
does something to me it bothers me
you're telling me that you're not part
of a community yeah so what if somebody
turns their car around in your car how
does it affect your [ __ ] property
value how does it affect you so every
time I see those cones robbing my wife
it burns me up inside it's already one
that I was really and I ran over them I
just saw them and I go wait look at this
[ __ ] and when you run over them
the ring goes on the lights go on it's
hilarious
oh yeah there's two sets if I go in and
out and I bang them again so yeah I'm
driving home eyes [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't
remember till the next day and dog I
seen those cones out there and I didn't
there's also a sign that says don't hit
the cones boom I hit the sign - just out
of principle
I hope the right I made a left on Colfax
I was done home yeah surprise even lit
them on fire oh that's a good idea
see I don't I don't
I've never lived in a neighborhood we're
like you could put cones
that's douchey yeah yeah like I remember
some of my neighbors would dry cuz like
I you've been in my neighborhood yeah it
was fun it would drive me nuts I'm the
white guy like you have your music
blasting I like 2:00 in the morning I'm
like a my neighborhood they they were
trying to put the trash cans out to save
parking spots and [ __ ] would
just throw your trash on the floor oh
yeah hey because rotted or else I'll run
it over another doctor corner here
people would do it it's up there with
you
yeah they will protect garbage you're
funny your car hole that would be coming
home in the car me
one of the morning I'll take the garbage
down next morning I wake up they're out
there sweeping their garbage
Elias I caused havoc in this
neighborhood
yeah was a guy who was parking here you
didn't like any other pickup trucks you
just put all your drinks for a year
although I used to Portela the cat
litter from my house with the cat [ __ ]
uh-huh I would pour in the back of his
car
no way and then we why because the dog
they would park there and go away on
vacation ah [ __ ] - so they would see the
train connects over here mm-hmm so what
people would do is either they would
park their car here that's free and then
take the train to bearbank Airport can
you take a train a Burberry shuttle so
that's what they do so a lot of these
[ __ ] want to save on money so
they parked on this street during the
holidays okay so that was a black truck
one time that no Lilly parked in front
of my house he took up two parking spots
all right that's a decent that's a
direct offensive [ __ ] you I stopped
there for three days and I figured out
what I could do this is gonna be slow
torch I want just to be a slow Houdini
type torture so I who did this
[ __ ] from A to Z this is gonna
be Jan Michael Vincent did you see the
professional yes what did you see if
this recently no I see I see the one the
old one right the one with the chick did
a little get a little girl on that guy
and the guy yeah the guy from a [ __ ]
Godzilla God have you seen it
yeah that [ __ ] is hard you know the
pieces I don't know the mom right they
killed the mom the family yes but at the
end he kills the whole building it
stinks as he and as he's walking out the
cop it's he's one of the best actors in
the game right now
I forget look up the professional tell
me who's in it please you have a minute
hey I can imagine your brain G but you
called the professional or is it
something else the profession it's
called the professional it's a shame
we're supposed to do [ __ ] the Comedy
Store tonight I know I was excited to
come out I'm you know gene we don't gary
oldman gary oldman plays the confident
moving and he steals the [ __ ] show
but I don't know if you don't remember
how that movie ends that Gary Oldman
kills that little girl's family
yeah because he said there was heroin
missing there were a heroin family so at
the end when he's walking out and don't
tell me spoiler alert [ __ ] the movies
20 years old yeah you haven't seen it go
[ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] dummies why are you spoiling her
learn I've never seen it will go [ __ ]
yourself it's 20 years old by now
what's older than that yeah so at the
end there he goes then Gary Oldham he
spots the professional dressed as a cop
he sneaks out i canna bollec this [ __ ]
he switch costumes with the cop uh-huh
and he snow this one cuz he took his
mask off to breathe and then there and
then the professional walks out the
building and Gary Oldham shoots him in
the back of the head and then they would
think the professionals laying there
like this and he looks up in Gary Oldman
stands over them and [ __ ] the
professional puts his hand up just take
this this is for Allie know cause he was
Natalya heavy accent and Gary Oldman
doesn't know what it is he takes his
hand he looks at it it's just a ring
with a faint and then he figures out
this is a linchpin and also the guy's
jacket there's grenades he blows up
that's how the movie ends he hits
tremendous yeah they stole her from the
mechanic 1973 yeah Jan Michael Vincent
yes same move Jan Michael gets into the
car there's a note from Charles Bronson
if we got back here and you're my car is
because you killed me I said Oh for
filament this cause
blow up in 20 seconds and he's going to
call blows up and the movie ends that's
but he kills Charles Bronson in Italy so
it's the same thing what we told him
about know we were talking about how you
were thinking from A to Z he had a
sabotage this guy's truck but okay
so I said [ __ ] this has to be a slow
torture yeah so number one I'm gonna
start with just garbage he parked it
like in December 23rd so I knew he
wasn't gonna come back to January yeah
so I had to give him a surprise
plus he had to take a surprise to go
okay you needed to take a surprise to go
so what I did was I thought can filled
it up with garbage first I started
emptying the trash can no no no what
evidence does receipts okay okay
I will hit him with like a soda from a
diet soda from a banana peel whatever I
what the 7-eleven I get a [ __ ]
protein bar I withdraw the [ __ ] wraps
in the back of his car
if I took my daughter to McDonald's and
she was a baby I would throw the trash
out put it in the backseat later on that
night at dramas that went for about ten
days it was filled with trash so not in
Dolphy was coming back for new years so
I had to work my magic like on the 29th
so I started just entering a litter I
would get home at 9:00 about one of the
more haha hold and I had three cat
litter box I got three two guy got three
[ __ ] then the moment smell on that oh I
just kept putting them back there
putting them back put them back there so
then I want I wanted to make sure he's
not coming back on that area toward I
thought he was still 31st
I took the guts on one tire the one on
the inside so he has to figure out how
to get a jack in there yeah and really
work it and they don't even know they
have a flat yeah see inside the gut I
take the gut up oh okay I have that
piece it takes to get up I know what you
mean now the aygos
yeah then you put that back in so they
think they have a flat you just took the
gutter and hand it out so now I have to
do a three frame
frong I want him to fix the flat and
think he's good he's out of it no he has
to do is dump the [ __ ] trash trash
uh-huh I figured I'd open up his gas cap
I put like 20 little balls of saran wrap
in there like six cents around the
wrapped balls that means within a week
once he got rid of the trash and once he
fixed the bike the tire huh now that the
car was gonna start to stall but at
weird times because wants to add his
truck was that old but it probably still
had a car tire on or something so once
once it gets warm in the car and the gas
gets warm cellophane expands so it
starts covering spots oh yeah one minute
you're on the 405 the loss on your car
stop hit by 10 cars and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
you think you're dealing with what if I
do you think you're dealing with these
are all the teachings of Fred I can't
say is last night I got you Fred used to
feel that why it's somebody it's
somebody wants so when you put maple
syrup and somebody's gas case Wow
because maple syrup tastes the gasoline
and turns it into a [ __ ] nightmare so
what happens is after about three days
your car starts to store they take it to
the fronton thing they pull off the
engine they can't figure out why y'all
are stalling even whatever things about
the maple maple syrup and [ __ ] saran
wrap in your gas tank stuff but in a
week you'll see it [ __ ] with a broken
arm like in king penguin Ernie McCracken
cause sugar yeah you put sugar on your
guests to have yeah that's where all
that [ __ ] come from you just seized up
an engine you just seize up the engine
it was so popular what was that what was
the crazy [ __ ] you threw in the trunk
and in the back of the truck though the
crazy
thing I think I ever did one of the
funniest I am very fortunate like you
George
fortunately the sense of God took us off
the street for a while and pull us back
on the show us with the realities in
life you and I both know that we could
have fell into the system yeah I'm in
there right now scratching with Colvin
ready to dive you're in prison right now
you're dead you might as well sign your
obituary there's riots if you've risen
listening right now you're dead I'm
sorry to tell you you shouldn't have
stole the hose you should have killed
the [ __ ] witness you're [ __ ] up
you're dying it's all over you don't
even need the electric chair if you got
a non-violent crime you might get out
there's always a way but if you got a
violent crime you're gonna sit there -
groans Ruth
you are telling me how we're lucky to be
out off the streets the craziest thing
you do and the craziest thing you did -
you put in someone's truck car for
parking in the front in 1986
I got a job at a place then I [ __ ] it
was really hard I was trying to get a
second chance of life and this job was
presented to me the problem was it was
the opening scale of the job and it was
probably basically working for free I
enjoyed the job so much I was a shag
around a body shop and I enjoyed the job
because eventually you graduated into
becoming a detailer and you went from
working 60 hours and getting $200 a week
for 60 hours oh my god to working 60
hours in makin 1,500 a week oh that was
a reality in 1987 86 in my world
how much is what's that equivalent to
what is now oh my god that's mad money
right yeah that's a grant everything
yeah that was these guys with detailing
new cars I forget what they were getting
and they were piece of cake you could do
ten hours in a day 15
hours for those and all you do is take
the cosmoline off which is the chemical
they put on the on the car
haha I was on the ship of protective
clothing yeah and exactly water [ __ ]
exactly put the mats out huh never put
the mats in it put the windshield wipers
on it's not more of a wash it's more of
a prep mm-hmm that's all it was it took
you an hour 45 minutes once you you knew
how to do it you just yeah I would do
two at a time like I get out I'll pull
to it break them both it's both the same
time that the chemical has to stick to
stay on there to break the cosmoline and
I would just wait hosing down dry them
up put the windshield wipers on take the
mats out of the backseat sometimes you
got to put the rim coverings yeah I know
engine eyes put arm roll on the wheels
put some armor all around the [ __ ]
thing and dope it up boom I could do ten
of those a day used cars with two and a
half hours why because they take time
they use cars gonna get a q-tip yeah
hanging back yeah so armor-all and do
this cute I was getting in there at 6:00
in the morning the kid says for the AC
air for the AC and the [ __ ] thing I
know all that [ __ ] I could be tell a
carb one in four 140 and we would split
it 50/50 or something like that
it was great money and then that's where
I met the dude that I could not Bella
with he installed stereos the speakers
there he was a an idiot in the back but
the point of the story was when I got
the job there you get promoted to be a
detailer and pending on how hard you
work I hate those other shaggers alive
yeah look I ate him alive that's you you
call - after I ate him alive
they couldn't even walk you know you had
to be there at 7:00 I was there at 6:00
and I was snorting coke that yes I was
gonna say not a lot of coke because I
was flat broke but I had no off to do
nothing to be I was there at 6:00 you
were working
good night I was getting that job and my
girlfriend were pick me up at [ __ ]
six o'clock you're the enjoyable but
that job was the burrito lady she came
at ten o'clock and she made these green
chili we had potato burritos right with
eggs wrapped in aluminum foil they were
this big
I'd buy like a those [ __ ] she
had me on the credit program where you
buy on Friday and then there was a team
there was the Baltimore Colts
were then and their father there was no
there were two brothers that play for
the Baltimore courts Kevin call and
another guy ciear wonk one of them was a
badass
he was an offensive lineman they had a
cover like the dude against the Jets the
head back in the 80s almost offensive
lineman this guy [ __ ] covered kevin
call his father had the Roach coach so I
would buy I would sell the father stolen
cigarettes I had a place like a steel
Carter the cigarettes from and I would
go in there and take like ten cartons of
cigarettes give it to mr. Coll he would
give me credit
never more expensive in the East Coast
to write cigarettes all this is Colorado
okay this is Colorado gee oh [ __ ] slower
some of them mr. Cole but let's get to
the basics of this this place where I
worked at I finally got promoted and I
finally became a detailer and once I
became a detailer I put the same passion
into detailing into being the shut up
detailer because I had never made this
type of money before this I was slinging
coke money made sure I went in there the
[ __ ] work jack I kept that job for
like seven months six months and I
[ __ ] was there at all times
[ __ ] that was became my life
it got me close like I was no better the
whole yeah you're like if there's a time
to work it's not X I'm not doing
anything else in my life so I just went
down and I started picking up those $59
checks and I was getting [ __ ] you know
I was getting flushing how old are you
it was
1987 I was 20 for you it was 886 so you
was like Flitz I mean fit slim yeah
dressy new six like how was your dress
back enjoy leather change that okay
white sneakers nothing has changed I
don't know why today's probably white
converse genius white t-shirt gold chain
no leather in Colorado
no why not you would scare white people
Oh
because yeah what's the reason [ __ ]
that's his clothes [ __ ] Oh God knows too
much to wear leather you just stuck out
like a sore thumb I mean when I moved to
LA you know many people I scare with
that leather jacket
now what's cause people do they can't
handle it damn I used to wear a leather
jacket I'm um I used to go to news radio
shootings and Joe Rogan was on news
radio okay and Joe Rogan will come up to
me laying around and go dog you're
scaring these white people I go how do
you know what he goes cuz they're
talking about it who's that scary guy
with the leather jacket on
he has more people once you're out once
you're west of the Mississippi yeah yeah
what a trip yeah yeah it scares white
people hey give him like you know it's
not something how many people you see
with leather jackets but if they do
whether the jackets the kind of stylish
in lausanne yeah yeah exactly but this
[ __ ] place five point three months
like when I first got in as a detail I
will I wasn't really one of them they
were [ __ ] on me because I was a
shagger
like an apprentice guy yeah but now when
I was one of them they would still bust
my balls they would still bust my balls
in time the time and now I had a
different boss and the guy in counter
was this guy called Dirk Johnson a dirt
Jordan Dirk Johnson and he had his own
crew so there was eight Detailers but
five of them were in his crew oh there's
a click yeah was it click they will
always get the preemie cause ah and the
other three dudes would get whatever the
[ __ ] we got where we got it that's why I
started going to six
so yeah early start so I will get there
and pulled two new ones to guarantee my
first hundred for the back by the time
he got in had already made a hundred
bucks okay
I was already was at five thousand a
week I had overtime there there was
overtime there so it was just so weird
that I was a cocaine dude not every
night then cuz I didn't have the money
and I knew I had gotten a second chance
and had to pay a bunch of bills off so I
was such a hard worker there that they
kind of got mad at me George I know what
you mean like the other guys look down
like ain't making me look really dog you
gotta come in at 6:00 you know what the
[ __ ] you can't come in at 7:00 and then
they got mad cuz I was coming in at 6:00
and picking up the juicy stuff well the
place opens at 4:00
beat me out yeah beat me out [ __ ] get
here in 5t park our places ago nobody
did that [ __ ] so they kept complaining
to to Dirk Jordan Dirk Johnson whatever
his name was
and now Dirk started writing me but I
had a friend in the partner the owner of
that place huh turned into a friend and
the guy I was in charge of service
turned into a friend so I went to them
and I'm like this guy's riding me get
him off of me because the one guy was
from New York
I said get him off me because I'm a
knock on the [ __ ] out yeah this guy's
confused and every morning Dirk let's go
the next time you come here before me
and get our authorization this is a nice
one dad just grabbed Michael stay right
there
I wanted her back when I got the hole
and I go come in for a second you know I
was like what's going on Joe go tell him
what you just told me tell him and he's
like whoa if that he comes here at since
he goes hey where I come from the early
bird gets the warm Missouri so Dirk had
egg on his face
so now Dirk would let me steal those two
cars in the morning and then he would
give me cars from like 1952 to make me
put him back to life so I have to spend
the next hour there so I got him to move
so then having like two other little
white dudes and make little remarks in
me from time that
you know I knew my friends with it oh we
did sailing your armor-all sucks
like what you didn't they would say
something to me well you're not staying
late tonight I got you know I would my
girl from those days I would need lunch
at 12 Howie is five I can live off a
breakfast burrito tray now as I would
buy like two or three breakfast burritos
and I would be eating them while I
worked I didn't want to take a lunch who
they would take an hour lunch [ __ ] that
was my lunch and then at 5:00
how would he's launching they wouldn't
make no remarks to me but I had already
made 300 for the day once I ate them
once I made 300 then you eat well until
you make 300 there ain't no me that was
a discipline in my head that was it and
that was even when I was [ __ ] up I
wasn't that [ __ ] up don't ever get me
wrong
well you're a I was still a high so this
dude kept riding me when they saw one
that went in there five in the morning
what do I see
I see a dead rat on the floor he got
caught by a trap and I hate
[ __ ] dead rats yeah why I said
oh [ __ ] I got an idea
I took the whole trap against my best
wishes
I got a good glove on the towel and I
carried that [ __ ] I hit him
behind the garbage and the Duke came at
his name was Dirk whatever Dirk Jordan
Dirk Johnson huh GJ whatever his [ __ ]
name is
he's [ __ ] hearing aids make my ears
itch he is [ __ ] you know that yeah I can
tell it's all good brother you guys
those and a half phones that's inchi oh
my god so so the mouse the rats behind
the trash it's [ __ ] rat had to be 5
inches and the click head caught him
like and a half way in and you can see
his teeth and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm gonna do
this so I hit him behind a garbage can
oh and this [ __ ] dude Dirk came in
with his two little competence and they
made whatever remarks they wallets her
and he hung his jacket up I had the rat
hidden over here and he hung his jacket
right over there my dog this guy don't
know it's a little by little I got the
courage up my foot down on the trap and
I picked up the [ __ ] thing and he was
dead
yeah I'd like to kick them out of the
trap and the rat fell and I had to get
like a paper towel and at lunchtime when
nobody was watching I took the rap on
the tail and I put it in his jacket
pocket
oh [ __ ] I like covered the jacket pocket
and I kept working at five o'clock
I took my lunch and [ __ ] and then I
[ __ ] that met my girlfriend picked me
up at the time and I went home but I
forgot all about dirt the next one I go
in there six you know me I get my two
new cars I'm trying to make my house
alive and all of a sudden I hear a car
we're working it's on the body shop is
on yeah usually when it's moving people
are [ __ ] getting work or there's
people are dropping off cars tow trucks
are pulling up the burrito lady's there
and also Dirk Jordan [ __ ] pulls up
his car's all dented like he had an
accident sure right like it was all
[ __ ] up okay who the [ __ ] did this
because I would to reach in my pocket
for a cigarette I took out a rat you
know meat though I just thought that
just laughing inside and he knew he was
me and his boys are gonna try to get me
but it was too late I had already been
transferred to bill crop Subaru as a
[ __ ] salesman so suck my dick and
call me shorty I was born in 1948 I'm
saying oh [ __ ] that was good
hey speaking of Mouse's and rats you got
cats and my cats are inside cats and
like they go outside now to see like to
let the other cats know what's so [ __ ]
we live here too this is our area but
lately these [ __ ]
been like killing Gophers and mice and
like bringing them to my window black
just to show me what's up what's up this
morning one of the Gophers outsmarted
these [ __ ] he he played the
best dad I've ever seen Joey like like
he had one arm here the tail like the
cats took his tail off uh but like they
tested them like I was tripping out so
Georgie Hanley you can't get out of
there you can't let them know especially
it's with this home a bat and you done
hey I would to move the Gopher to check
out if it was like really like cuz like
I could see it was like yo da this fool
was like holding his breath in like you
he was waiting for the Fuhrer move no I
just kept by his tail up because they're
crazy that's how I didn't see him get
his tail bit off but the tail was not
there and it was laying next to him and
like he was playing dead cuz my cat was
trying to play with it once I go maybe
my cat's name is bait it was baby and
Rick James state they terrorize these
things and I was like come here and like
I shook their food and they walked over
there that fool jumped up dog
I swear grabbed his channel that will
took off would in the dirt and I was
like oh my god they get out on their own
don't give a [ __ ] you know what put them
in [ __ ] canary oven you imagine how
lucky we do with that left up George
what a different time for it is this
great that's great you know what uh
speaking of locked up in your shirt you
know what that sweater that reminds me
of and I just seen the show and I wanted
to ask you about it cuz I don't think I
was old enough but the Waco shooting
have you seen that on Netflix
I know but you know you you you lived it
that week it's two anniversaries that
are big for me today is the anniversary
of the 40 anniversary of the Mario
Harbor Cuba opened up no it's today when
my mom died she was six months away she
my mom were the last is six months my
mom would have picked up her daughter in
Cuba Wow that was the plan they didn't
know they didn't know all that
disruption oh what's going on
Fidel took over right the DAAD took it
over he had had the islands that swept
in 1959 but then he sat everybody what
happened was there was little the Cuba
was going through hard economic times
mm-hmm the Russians had pulled out the
Cubans were out of money
people were starving so people started
invading little embassies and they would
get throw him back into the society and
then we'd get shot and the embassies
finally took notice that this is [ __ ]
crazy
so they said anybody who wants to leave
Cuba show up here at 7:00 the morning
[ __ ] 2000 people showed up and kicked
the gates down they went the war for a
couple of days that the Cuban army they
had to get like the the security from
the embassy I'm hard to go to war with
the Cuban police this is crazy so this
one I'm so finally but the disruptions
were starting already when my mother was
still alive like you were hearing
disruption yeah you've already never try
no no they were really trying to get the
blackmail out that America was bad and
Miwa will [ __ ] start like like I just
got six eggs for my family for the month
and how is America bad Real Talk then
they started saying so send us money so
if you sent your family 500 bucks the
Cuban government would only give you on
a $25
the rest of the human government would
take so all that unrest started when my
mother was alive
I remember hearing all about it's so
weird didn't he take Sheila Easton's
house too or something like that Lu Cruz
Sandia she least my best [ __ ] San
Francisco so good but that was all 59
okay this is we're talking about 75 now
okay what's Russia realized that what's
the only thing Cuba can't do nothing for
you except give you sugar yeah they're
not gonna bust a grape that's it they
got no money so Russians pulled out with
financing things want a sow that's why
the Dow had it going to the narco
traffic hunting business how can all
these shows that they put about narco
they tell the CIA and they throw
everybody on the nobody has thrown Fidel
yet you're so right
tiller show toes Fidel under that's when
I'm paying attention because that's when
you did your homework you know once Cuba
was broke Cuba went to the Colombians
and said hey you want a new route what
are the route and how far is Cuba from
Miami now had the Imams how many 90
miles oh they were shipping the tons
into Cuba and then they were breaking it
up into delivery so it was like one on
sugar and looks like sugar ready so it
was like a million kilos were coming in
and then they were going on ten
different boats with a million kilo on
each boat Wow oh it's got in seven boats
out of whatever god that's that's great
seven out of ten
Oh seven out of ten so Fidel was making
money I think the dough was making a
hundred thousand his [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz well
years later when Carlos way there
testified to reduce his sentencing he
mentioned he spoke about because I
remember giving him envelopes to his
face
eight hundred thousand [ __ ] that's what
he negotiated
I'll send ten ships out of day ten get
in I get eight million if six getting a
4.2 million you know he just knew
how to wrangle them they've never
mentioned that they'll talk about how
the government Mexico knew about the
sinaloans how they win the president
Mexico poster don't tell you all that
stuff they'll tell you how whoever shot
President Kennedy but they still won't
release the Castro I mean do you think
it's because America was kind of in on
it like the people here listen they Ward
that we found that we went in it on
their ear and conscious sample we were
trading weapons for drugs and cash
weren't we with the Sun and Easter's a
lot on it yeah if you watch knuckles all
that [ __ ] is true oh yeah you're right
yeah all that [ __ ] is true then what's
the guy the white dude 1 in front of
Congress and he got thrown under the bus
for giving the CIA I don't know I don't
know the whole [ __ ] breakdown of
everything I'm just telling you that you
know these are the realities that you
find out later on that they tell you so
who the [ __ ] knows what else you gonna
do for 420 what do you got cooking
tonight a Monday night well you know I'm
sorry show we got dr. III I'm doing your
podcast Monday morning and then tonight
all you do it no yeah
I got my own podcast going on I got like
about 4 or 5 people that live in my
house and we are before we podcast we
all take that [ __ ] shower we do a
Lysol inspection on each other or your
local wipes at the hands clean the table
off with the clothes cleaning supplies
from work and we're gonna have a little
420 podcast you know what I mean okay I
am thinking about cuz there's a stripper
that works with me and she's just like
you're bad that's six people so they're
gonna get shut down kick will kick side
dick Katie elf that's your name and you
know listen guys I'm gonna be honest
with you I got a lot of [ __ ] people
pissed off for me they were pissed you
know why because you were coughing and
they know what the [ __ ] was going on and
they were concerned so I thought
about stopping the podcast for a while
and and then I figured what good would I
do at the time that you need you know
comedy and humor and just a little
[ __ ] inspiration what a time to close
it so I decided to do everything but we
can't do deck which he won't do he's
been on quarantine for three years and
you know I put the time I put the guest
on that you know I think I'm pretty
clean so you don't want to get you
infected ain't wanna get in fact that I
wanted but I always wanted to put
content that you I don't care if I got
to come in put a ukulele by myself once
a week for an hour straight up I will
come here and give you some type of
content to think about to take your mind
off what's going on right straight up
it's 4:20 again we can't even smoke a
joint like human beings because this is
the future now all edible thank God a my
edibles to have that edible you leave he
had the mask over his eyes hey doesn't
he look like a weird ninja it feels like
a weird then she's had a rough couple
weeks talk
yeah I gave garlic pills I can't had a
boom he thought he was down for one day
he had been down for a day and a half
yeah that's how bad it was yeah have you
ever had cilantro pills after all giving
them next garlic pills almost [ __ ]
killed them to clean the other system II
think you really like take so many shits
at like 2:00 in the morning you have to
take a shower yeah that's what that's
how good the garlic is oh my god I do
that every [ __ ] day twice a day
you ever had actually now during this
quarantine you can't do [ __ ] no this was
sort of build your [ __ ] them yellow
paper who gives a [ __ ] Lee this warrant
on the paper would you rather be healthy
don't worry about [ __ ] toilet paper
that's why you got a [ __ ] bidet don't
just too strong for the bidet yeah you
you know she's stronger yeah your
[ __ ] whiff
I can't imagine what your [ __ ] must
know like with Mohammed
and the McDonald's and the old she got
stuck up there it's like a grand but
like you somebody get the toy like right
now they catch you on the street past 8
o'clock
you should be sentenced to a week of
sniffing Lee's [ __ ] take away the
corona and to [ __ ] and make you check
so what thank God for that
it smells like the back of that truck
George Perez I'm happy you came out so
thank you brother I'm happy this time
I'm 420 and [ __ ] hey y'all going through
[ __ ] we're all going through [ __ ] we're
gonna make the best of it because that's
what the [ __ ] we do here on the church
even with a [ __ ] mask on the last
time I wore masks you don't know what we
don't want to know what I was doing you
know I'm saying straight up last time I
had a mask on you know I don't know what
the [ __ ] I was doing but this is the new
norm I don't want to do that [ __ ]
zoom [ __ ] where you know I gotta pop my
head up I mean nothing you know so we
try we started take clean we leave the
door open we sanitize you know me I
don't go nowhere without my [ __ ] let
me get that little Kathleen telling me
or foot there
hey Halloween's gonna be easy now though
with we got a lot of practice with mask
gives a [ __ ] about Halloween we got to
make it the Halloween make it 4th of
July
don't worry about Halloween right George
praise Oh promote your dates but we got
hopefully June 4th to the 6th oh let us
do bread I appreciate you guys taking
the time to support the podcast
thank you George Perez don't forget your
podcast is called George Perez stories
on [ __ ] iTunes anything with a church
what's happening now we got [ __ ]
YouTube iTunes and there you go see
listen on Spotify and all I could do is
wish you a happy 4/20 don't forget to
get high as [ __ ] and don't forget to be
humble - thank you
thankful we're still alive you still got
your help and prayers out everybody is
suffering and also a [ __ ] big hug to
all the [ __ ] out there in the
front line from the supermarket's to the
hospital to the nurses thank you for
what you doing the church appreciate you
I love you guys I'll see you Wednesday
morning kick this [ __ ] mealy
[Music]